welcome to this video playing anti-drone
again we had a green felt last time I
want something else and the gruene felt
I didn't really get anywhere so I got
into the vehicle system and you played
the line that I didn't didn't turn no
wait on so we switched to them check
where it goes in here yeah my bishop and
my queen a4 check line not super
ambitious but I really don't know any
other line and determine it is so bad or
anything just sometimes feels like there
should be something more exciting but
the kind of position idea I generally
like it's a little bit like though
exchange Queens gambit can go nite a 4 C
5 and poke around on the queenside a
little bit
oh it's hard to tell sometimes they play
b6 in those positions hmm like here I
lost them a pretty drastic game in this
this type of position in in a dual
commentary just like two weeks ago or so
or three weeks ago I don't know
something like that where something like
g5 was thrown at me and this is no I g5
is a normal idea but it got tricky
really quickly yeah so i think i'm going
to go g three bolts to that a little bit
maybe queen g7 FF for now hmm yah yah
yah yah yah it's kind of similar to that
game and maybe I'm just playing this
entirely wrong I mean possible
to make doing wrong the edge if I
perform
it's right that stuff looks bad already
up that looks like a bad position maybe
I maybe I should avoid g3 or something
then I cannot spend the agency are it
simply hate this position if I therefore
that such an easy attack to play and I
don't see my player at all there you
have GF is immediately threatening on g3
edits it's very very quick actually very
quick ah
it's a real nightmare position warhol I
wanted to go f 44 when NES Bishop g4
yeah that's the worst part of it this is
can be played this is so simple to play
amazing maybe just Queen f6 or something
and I'm lost nake than a five Queen f7
maybe
okay I mean it looks bad but at least
I'm not checkmated like in two or three
moves which is more than I mean I feel
even worse things happening to me even
though that is still pretty rotten so
that some groups is six maybe that I can
irritate them with probably not Lucas is
six rupee 8th star and if I go outside
queen age 5 is got Queen D for
unfortunately maybe this for up to 5
rupee 80 t 5 25 Knight f6 check work T
525 Knight f6 check it's not great even
then it's not great
you
maybe that's not even working huh yeah
it is kind of working a case
it really was worse earlier Queenie for
probably hmm but again I think I was
actually in worse shape early in the
game so everyone maybe try to who would
the rook endgame my can go quickly to I
can take you on the subject rugby tubes
is some good be three anyway I'm glad I
can be really satisfied that i didn't go
check made it quickly it was certainly
not out of the picture that I got
quickly quickly made it
time morning g63 is kind of his
promoting now k that's that I get just
giving a wage to him yeah I can the
Rogaine game still was bad yeah up did
to rook t to check yeah in an earlier
game he somehow miraculously promoted
into a night in a completely winning end
game and this is why I'm continuing
instead of a queen I was really strange
hmm I really have to look at this
opening line I mean this opening result
is really unacceptable Oh Kim white
resigns yeah I mean I could somehow
fight but this is just completely bad
this position so what is wrong there
then this is a theoretical position
nitey for is that bad I don't believe it
b6 maybe this is rubbish I don't know I
mean g3 is probably wrong that is
probably just wrong I forgot about that
[ __ ] g7 at five idea but black has got
that anyway what is what is what is my
play in this position I mean this is a
position that night a for our business
that has been played by carlton against
the Rohingya and it's not like this is
some putts s opening with white so what
is different I mean okay Aronian really
played badly in this game but they think
they had almost this position probably
jewy g3 is bad well let's in by a given
by the engine by the engine initially
five and now computer gives King h1 some
engine lines are really funny King edge
one then it gives rook ft 8 which is
totally illogical you play on the effort
somehow and then you move the rook away
then stop which gives before and now a
g4 for black g-form want to move and c5
I do really don't see any human playing
like that ever it does make some sense
don't get me wrong I mean that this is a
weird way of playing g4 and so on but
Jim ok this is this is basically losing
what I was already be desperate I mean
black just test is a tech and what does
white have yeah this this this yeah
summer I was hanging on for a little bit
at least 18 25 yeah this is check the
computer gives this the shine with the
clear advantage I don't know yeah I mean
you went up teeth into this rook endgame
maybe I have to do something else now
chan chan but yeah white being stuck on
the second rank is just too much I was
still hoping I mean with the root can't
give up on down you you very often have
some kind of chances to fight but tiered
looks entirely lost with the rook on the
second yeah I really have to look at
this line that was a terrible opening
result thanks for watching